Thank You Hall H we'll see you next time
love you thank you
Marvel blew the roof off at comic-con
2019 but what does it all mean for phase
four
we're here to break it all down for you
right now hello friends and welcome to
the ketchup the new show from Ryan
tomatoes where we explore with the
latest movie and TV news means to you
after skipping comic-con 2018 Marvel
came in full force this time around
basically giving us a reason to live
until 2021 and proving endgame truly
wasn't the end of the world
you guys Hall H was happening on
Saturday night H stands for happening
with one of the most mind-blowing
announcements being Marvel's first
horror film that's right guys Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness is
coming in May of 2021
and with some of the darker themes and
concepts explored in the comics it is no
surprise that director scott derrickson
promised Hall H that he's gonna make
quote the first scary MCU film yup pick
that job off the ground this doesn't
make any sense
not everything does the first Doctor
Strange is a certified fresh' 89% on the
tomato meter and we know that Benedict
Cumberbatch will be joining the sequel
by Elizabeth Olsen as Scarlet Witch the
movie will be a direct follow-up to her
Disney Plus show WAN division which was
also announced it's unclear who else
will join the cast but some are
theorizing that Scarlet Witch will
actually turn evil and become the main
villain and it's heavily rumoured that
the very dark character nightmare could
be involved as the bad guy but either
way fans are pumped like this user who
tweeted Doctor Strange too is a horror
film the MC is finally going dark after
being super goofy for years I couldn't
be happier
assuming that everyone who writes in
caps is screaming right and another who
said Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness is the Kulish another shocking
announcement to come from the Marvel
panel was the introduction of blade into
the MCU
with two-time Oscar winner Maher Sheila
Ali in the role cue the club horn oh no
one saw this coming guys and it's just
so happens that Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige told us how that all came
together
mahalo wants come in and meet with us
and when Mohali wants to meet you take
the meeting
and i think he had just come off of his
second Academy Award and we were talking
very polite and he was talking about
what Fanny is and then he just cut right
to it and was like blade and we were
like yes so now you guys remember the
blade trilogy from the late 90s and
early 2000s with Wesley Snipes
it was classic Wesley well despite a
rotten average of 45% on the tomato
meter fans are definitely excited to see
the character back on the big screen at
some point and some are already planning
their outfits for their premiere and by
the way speaking of Oscar winners one of
the most surprising Marvel announcements
came in the form of the next Thor movie
Thor love and thunder are you sitting
down for this one
Natalie Portman is taking over as female
thorn it'll be in theaters in November
of 2021 and don't worry hardcore Thor
fans Chris Hemsworth will still be in
the movie too along with Tessa Thompson
who co-starred in the certified fresh'
Thor Ragnarok in 2017 she will be the
first Marvel LGBTQ superhero what a time
to be alive
Portman played Thor's human love
interest Jane Foster in the first two
Thor films but then seemed to step away
from the role
so her brief appearance in the certified
fresh' avengers endgame earlier this
year along with this announcement has
fans on Twitter saying things like
Natalie Portman is Thor if I'm dreaming
don't wake me up and everyone everyone
Shh Natalie Portman plain core is the
only thing I'm gonna talk about from now
until forever and if we're gonna be
talking about surprise casting details
we have to talk about the Eternals y'all
rumors were confirmed that Angelina
Jolie is going to be in it and she's
playing FINA the inspiration for the
Greek god Athena and being that Angelina
Jolie is in fact an actual goddess she
just makes sense I know what I'm gonna
be for Halloween now and Marvel also
revealed that Salma Hayek who will be
the leader of the Eternals and Lauren
gridlock are playing original male
characters from the comics and on top of
that Radloff is the first-ever
deaf actress and they'll be joined by
some pretty sick company Kumail Nanjiani
Richard Madden and Bryan
Tyree Henry and a diverse cast that
incredible is obviously going to turn
some heads quarter users went nuts
saying things like holy turtle's cast is
so far worse I'm crying and we're really
getting a deaf actress in the MCU and
that is something a party about along
with my personal favorite just wow and
if I may get a little nerdy for a minute
here how exactly will the Eternals tie
into the MCU is gonna be mucho talked
about along with the fact that Thanos is
technically an eternal they also tie to
the Celestials which we've seen in the
guardians of the galaxy movies and they
battled the Kree who you might remember
from both Captain Marvel and the
guardian movies not to mention agents of
shield so it's gonna be really
interesting to see how this all plays
out and since I just mentioned a great
Marvel TV show it's worth knowing that
dates and details were revealed around a
whole new slate of shows for the Disney
Plus streaming service and guess what
they will all be tied in to face for the
list is pretty epic and includes Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye Tom Hiddleston's Loki
Wan division with Olsen Scarlet Witch
and Paul Bettany vision and Falcon in
the Winter Soldier with Anthony Mackie
and Sebastian Stan so get your
checkbooks ready guys just kidding no
one uses those anymore but you know what
I mean cuz Disney's taken over the small
screen when do we start we just did and
if you're still with us and you're not
deceased and your mind is it's
officially blown yet add on top of that
the other movies that were announced
including guardians 3 Black Panther to
Captain Marvel 2 and shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings that one will
feature the iconic villain Mandarin the
real one not the one from Iron Man 3 you
get it as for beyond the year 2021
Feige confirmed at the panel that
Fantastic Four thanks to Disney's
acquisition of Fox and the mutants are
now in active development - and I'm just
gonna need to take a breather because
this is a lot you guys it's like
Christmas on steroids
the good news is our next taste of the
MCU as we've all assumed will be
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow coming
next May the panel announced that
actress Florence Pugh will be joining
the cast and that the movie will take
place between the events of Civil War
and infinity
or they also showed off some exclusive
footage to the room and since I wasn't
there to see it
I'll take scar Joe's word for how
intense a lot of fighting girls fighting
your own burrito it's a good time to be
a Marvel fan and apparently there is a
lot of them because the Marvel panel
opened with the news that Avengers
endgame officially passed avatar is the
top grossing movie of all time if that
isn't a mic drop I don't know what is I
know I know we just threw a lot at you
and there are so many crazy theories to
keep you up at night now so it is time
to kick it over to you now what are you
most excited for will you be getting
Disney Plus what do you think will be
revealed at Disney's d23 Expo in August
and is Disney in the Illuminati just
kidding don't answer that one but let us
know all your thoughts in the comment
section and for all the latest trailers
and news from comic-con head on over to
ron tomatoes calm and make sure to hit
that like and follow button because it
is free thanks for watching our new show
the ketchup as always I'm Nass Prez and
I'll see you guys next time
[Music]